here with reaction let's give a warm
welcome the co-host of the hit show The
Five Judge Jeanine Pirro is here
thank you
wow boy all right this is sure I don't
want to waste a minute with you because
you have so much to say
um and this is important so I believe
this indictment is real I think we're
going to see it if not this week
probably sometime next week yes okay
they might indict Hunter right around
the same time but it's going to be on a
gun application charge and tax charges
none of the things that Comer's
investigating about China and Ukraine
and Russia and monies and and uh
suspicious activity reports and and
shell corporations okay and foreign
lobbying and not registering as a
foreign agent remember Paul manafort was
in solitary confinement for that one
nearly two years yes yeah yes all right
so here's my question I don't think
they're going after Donald Trump on the
issue of documents no they can't okay so
if they do they have to go after Joe and
they have to go after Hillary that's
right okay that's right so I'm guessing
tell me if I'm wrong that they're going
to go after a process crime of course
they're going after a process crime they
can't possibly go after Donald Trump for
these documents first of all Hillary
let's get her out of the way right away
she was never a president she was never
a vice president she wants to be I think
she still wants to run but that's
another issue uh and the truth is for
her to have these classified documents
on a private email that Jim Comey said
probably was hacked by a foreign
government that she then destroyed which
is obstruction of evidence tampering
with evidence and 33 000 33 000
subpoinity peanut emails she knew about
the subpoena she knew it was relevant to
the uh to the investigation into
Benghazi okay so you absolutely cannot
let her go not even mentioning what
happened with Durham and the Durham
investigation now as it relates to Joe
Biden what we have right now is we have
something like I don't know 1850 boxes
from when he was a Senator he's got
records from when he was a Senator not
even allowed to have uh information
that's classified in various places in
four different locations classified but
they're not going after him so the only
way they can go after Donald Trump is
say oh somehow he obstructed something
or he did something to stop us from
getting this information when he was
working with the agency that's in charge
of these documents all right let's talk
about so originally the grand jury what
we heard was in Washington D.C we
thought the case the document case would
be in Washington D.C little did we know
that there was a another grand jury
convened and this one in Miami which
would be where the jurisdiction of
Mar-A-Lago is Right does that mean that
the j6 investigation aspect of the
special counsel is in D.C and the
Mar-A-Lago cases in Miami because I
don't think Donald Trump would have a
shot in Hell getting a fair jury in D.C
or New York or frankly Fulton County
Georgia for that matter right there's no
question but maybe Miami maybe Miami oh
you know what you've got is the January
6th event I don't know what they have
anything there I don't know that they
have evidence that they believe as
prosecutors many of you will now
peacefully and patriotically March so
your voices can be heard yeah yeah that
crime I forgot about that one uh but
then but what's going on in Mar-A-Lago
and the way they took them down the way
they went in there I mean it is shocking
what they did but this is a dual system
of justice there is no question that
there is a system for the bidens and his
son and by the way if they do indict
Hunter Biden I don't know anyone who's
paid two and a half million dollars in
taxes and back taxes who hasn't gone to
jail I mean that is itself what about
the guy that gave him the money lends
him the jet to go to his custody hearing
says he he doesn't want to pay for his
own yeah his own Oh you mean the
grandchild that the the bidens forgot
about I know Joe's forgetting things but
I think
they say they have six grandchildren
they have a seventh one and they only
put six up on I guess the fireplace you
forgot the dog the dog they've had the
dog had one on Stocking for the dog how
do you ignore a four-year-old innocent
little girl who is your biological
granddaughter that Joe and Jill Biden
where is your heart your soul and your
conscience that girl did nothing wrong
acknowledge that little girl and it gets
it gets worse than that Sean look it
goes to the character of the bidens
there's so so supposed to be so empathic
they're supposed to be so kind the truth
is they objected to that little girl
having Biden as a last name they went to
court to stop that they had a well I
don't think that might be a special gift
if she doesn't have the last name but
well given the organized criminal
Enterprise that we've seen not to use my
last name so I know all right but let me
let me let me ask you this because let's
go to the one case that we do know let's
go to the quid pro quo this is this is
Joe Biden on tape bragging oh he said I
I was in Ukraine he had a billion
taxpayer dollars one billion dollars and
he said I'm not giving you the billion
unless you fire a prosecutor why would a
vice president ever want a prosecutor in
Ukraine fire that's odd right well you
know why it makes sense it makes sense
because that was a company that his son
was working for and making 50 years
dollars a month I'm walking everybody
through the floor we're walking through
the okay okay so no vice president would
ever want a prosecutor in Ukraine fire
right and he says you got six hours to
do it and he's bragging telling the
story after the fact son of a beat they
fired him okay that prosecutor now you
can take it from okay so that prosecutor
ends up getting fired but here's the
outrage the outrage is a president of
the United States would wrap himself in
the flag of this country and all the
power and Prestige that goes with that
flag and go into a country and say if
you don't get rid of this prosecutor on
this individual company by the way that
my son and all his buddies are getting
money from I I'm not going to give you a
billion dollars from the United States
that's our taxpayers dollars and you
know what he's dumb enough to come out
and say he said it that as far as I'm
concerned is a pay to play and add to it
I mentioned earlier Hunter on Good
Morning America no experience getting
paid all this money I listen he's got no
experience and Joe knows nothing about
his foreign businesses are you kidding
why would he lie about that that's
called consciousness of guilt let me ask
you a final question yes we appreciate
you being here we're kind of ending each
other's sentences no that's true
um uh I want to ask you about how what
how does this impact Donald Trump's Run
for the presidency because I don't think
it's just going to be this special
counsel I believe Fulton County is a
done deal too I think so he's not going
to be facing New York Fulton County
Miami and then maybe Miami NDC with
legal problems the this is not a small
issue how do you run successfully for
president with all of that hanging over
your head the whole time well first of
all I think Donald Trump has proven
based upon his four years in office that
he can withstand what none of us could
withstand I mean I'd be hiding under a
desk all right that's number one number
two
you know maybe one indictment maybe one
but if you do two three four indictments
then you're gonna have you will have
poked the eye of the tiger at that point
I think Americans see a dual system of
justice we see it on the local level
with the defunding of police we see it
on the federal level with the Department
of Justice calling parents domestic
terrorists and with the non-indictment
of people that we know viscerally are
are should be charged with a crime I
think it in yours to his benefit and I
think in the end people will see it that
way all right Judge Jeanine great to see
you thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else